The Joe Rogan experience and if I move,
if I had more stories I could get away with it.
But it,
but once you hear the joke,
you know it's over.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't,
doesn't work again.
Yes.
Seinfeld,
he's still does old,
old stuff and he does really old stuff and he's done two specials of old stuff
that he's,
that like he's already put on specials.
I went and saw him at the palladium,
uh,
about a year or two ago and it was one of the worst shows I've ever seen.
Like I had like a splitting headache and I was like furious really.
And one of my friends in other comic that I respect a lot gave him a standing
ovation and I was like,
are you fucking kidding me?
And he was like,
I understand why you feel the way you do,
but I just love seeing the act.
And I was like,
I couldn't believe it.
And then I saw Seinfeld again at cluster fest.
He was in the big outdoor stage with a bunch of like for kids completely
different hour and murdered like destroyed.
And it was like,
he has like corny stuff depending on what the audience,
you know,
is if everyone's sitting there wearing a Yamaka,
he's got one act and if it's a bunch of kids he's got,
he's got a cool hip act.
Really?
Yeah.
So you went to the Yamaka crowd?
Interesting.
What was bad about that?
It was a aggressively corny and just Courtney's a funny phrase like you'd be
like,
thank you for coming to the show.
I know,
you know,
we like,
or should we go to the show?
Should we go?
Should I,
should we go to the shows?
We get to be nuber.
How'd we get to the show?
Did we really want to go down?
I'm like,
I can't believe he's doing this right now.
But people were eating it up.
Like everyone around me was going nuts and loving it.
Uh,
but it was just like old man,
corny.
Oh Man.
Could you see Seinfeld on like a talk show and he's like mean kind of biting and
you're like,
oh,
this is great.
Like he's hilarious.
And I expected more of that.
But when I saw him in cluster fest,
I got that,
you know,
what does cluster fest?
It's that,
uh,
it's like,
it's the third year,
this year,
that festival in San Francisco.
It's a comedy central and Coachella put together a,
uh,
put together a thing.